if we want to be a little
tongue-in-cheek we can say that we're
now living in the era of poorly planned
and managed life-altering environment
changing technological rollouts and what
I have in mind is a YouTube's
integration with Google Plus which has
been going on for some time but has
drastically affected things in the last
day with something that would seem
fairly small but actually changes the
entire picture and that is comments so
I'm I've been prompted you might say I
never thought that I would be talking
much about technology or its effects on
our life because I'm a historian of
philosophy and I shoot videos that have
to do largely with with past thinkers
and I do a lot of application of how
these things could fit into your life
and I do communicate through YouTube as
well as a number of other technological
platforms but I know think I'd be doing
a lot of reflecting on that in videos
but now I've been prompted to do it in
part because I've kind of had it and
that can be a good prompt sometimes that
can be a good provocation at times and
what I want to do in this video is six
main things I want to communicate with
my viewers who are left completely in
the lurch when it comes to the
interaction that we have been having
over the last two and a half years in
some cases through comments which has
been a very important part of what it is
that I do with YouTube on YouTube and
through YouTube and it has to do also
with how people are able to interact
with with me how I'm able to do
philosophy as a scholar as a professor
as an educator on on youtube so Google
is really in a lot of ways rang a bell
that can't be unrung and you know the
other metaphors that go along with that
right so
thing I want to do is communicate with
my viewers and I'm going to do that in a
moment another thing is I wanted to talk
a little bit about some some history and
then the third thing is I want to talk
about what's actually wrong right now
with YouTube comments and how that's
just sort of the tip of the iceberg the
third thing I want to do is talk a
little bit about just sort of throw out
a teaser about something that I've been
thinking a lot about and wrote a blog
entry on a long time ago I'm my main
blog or excess do you know IDK about all
this integration of platforms the fourth
thing I want to talk about or the fifth
thing I want to talk about sorry is how
these new comments paradoxically they
have the potential to make for a really
social interaction which would be in
many respects much better than what we
currently have on YouTube but right now
it's just it's just a Bissell it's
thoughtful and the sixth thing I want to
talk about is how this is affecting the
whole process of providing elements of
Education via the net through YouTube
which has been one of the main ways of
delivering new content dwarfing
everything else so to my viewers I am
trying to figure out how I can actually
respond to comments as it turns out not
only am I unable to respond to older
comments just from last night or
yesterday and carry on threads of
conversation that we've had going for
sometimes weeks or even months or
intervene in canto common threads I
can't even respond to the new ones so
the only thing I may actually able to do
is work in Google+ and to say thanks for
subscribing or maybe you should check
this out by posting on your channels so
I'm really frustrated and I know you
must be frustrated as well because part
of what what's you know so cool about
YouTube is being able
to interact with with content creators
and and I've really enjoyed a lot of the
interactions that I've had with with
YouTube viewers over the years so I have
no idea what's going to go on but stick
with us and we'll see what happens you
know hopefully this is just a little
hiccup on the part of google plus but
we'll have to see in any case I'm going
to continue putting out videos I've got
the core concept videos coming out and
get some more existentialist stuff and
I'm going to shoot more of these
technology-based videos and I've got a
few other things in the works so the
second item here's what I'd like to say
to Google Google who do you think you
are Yahoo I mean we expect this sort of
idiocy and terrible poorly thought-out
attempts to integrate platforms together
and bring new features in from Yahoo
because I mean look at they managed to
turn for 10 years to buy up platforms
and to turn them into crap YouTube is
probably Google's besides its search
most important product out there the one
that has the greatest potential and they
tinkered with it I don't know whose
decision this was but I gotta tell you
google you need to hire people like me
who actually are a little bit closer to
ground level and are engaged with with
other users so we can tell you that's a
dumb idea don't do this don't force
everybody from YouTube into Google+
comments don't you know cut off the very
possibility of commenting on anything
from oh say two days ago because you're
damaging your product all perhaps in
relatively I mean Google can become
yahoo or i could say google who do you
think you are facebook i mean google+ is
sort of like you know facebook's little
rival it's not doing that well in
comparison to it but it's been getting
better and better and better and
Facebook has been
alienating users for years by rolling
out new features that users don't like
but they stick with it because facebook
is really the only game in town unless
Google+ takes off Twitter can't compare
linkedin us or something different the
other social networks just don't have
the sort of capacity but you know
facebook's stock is pretty stagnant and
that's because people have gotten hip to
the fact that these people don't really
know what they're doing their know all
about code and they know all about how
to bring about things but when it comes
to making users actually happy they're
not doing a very good job so Google you
want to be like them I mean I thought
you were trying to market yourself as
being something different now you're
showing yourself to just be more of the
same and if you're just going to be more
of the same hell let's go with Facebook
why bother with with Google and if
you're going to you know intrude into
another very very successful platform
that you happen to have brought up a
long time ago to YouTube then you better
do it right so you better start you know
bringing in people who actually have
some sort of sense for how these changes
are going to affect people so that
brings me to a three-point what's
actually wrong what's what's gone wrong
well you know the new comment I'm going
to call it the comment regime is just
sort of the tip of the iceberg I've
noticed some things getting stuck over
the last week or so in YouTube and I
thought well these are just little
glitches and these are things which
would probably not be all that apparent
too many users it's something that
content producers would be more attune
to for example yesterday I looked at my
my numbers and I saw that i was about to
break 700,000 views and I you know you
looked at the number as I go out and
just short it by that much it stayed the
same for over a day now you're telling
me that nobody has actually viewed
anything else up for this day no you
tube is somehow not tracking things the
way that they ought to be so there's
some glitches there
I actually had to write to some of the
the content producing help stuff because
I'm not able to modify my playlist the
way I used to they've got somehow shoved
into YouTube edu and there's no edit
button anymore that's a big problem
things are sort of getting fixed in
stone and that's not what we want out of
the web we want the capacity to actually
get in there and tinker with things I
think perhaps what was going on is
google told YouTube you just like hold
on to everything as it is while we push
these changes in so what are the changes
well the new comments in order to leave
a comment you actually have to do so
through some Google+ integration and you
know that that's got some interesting
features to it but the big problem is
all the previous comments on videos and
I have you know tens of thousands of
comments on my videos and some sites
have hundreds of thousands even millions
of comments on their videos they're all
frozen nobody can continue the
conversations nobody can add anything
nobody can can refute anything nobody
can continue an argument make a new
argument introduce some new information
linked to anything Google effectively
drop down something like a guillotine
that cut off the present from the past
and that is doing a lot of damage they
better figure out a way to incorporate
that or else all of those previous
comments they're not necessarily lost
their just frozen nobody can do anything
nobody can respond to them nobody can
point out whether they're brilliant or
stupid nobody can say that made me think
of this a lot has been lost because of
that and all it would have taken is a
little bit of thought to figure out
that's going to be the consequence of
this
I mean did they actually get anybody who
uses YouTube in on this decision that's
what I would like to know they
introduced here's a few other things
they introduced a feature to identify
spam what is likely to be spam and
filter it out now I've looked at some of
the things that the spam filter is
catching and a lot of it's not spam a
lot of it is actually legitimate
comments on my videos by people who took
the time to actually write something
either you know some of them are very
intelligent some of them perhaps not so
much but they took the time to do it
they invested their time and effort to
communicate with another person and the
spam filter that Google is using just
decided that their spam in the old
version I could actually look at it and
I could say that's not spam there's no
button to do that anymore it invites you
to review that the comments but it
doesn't let you do anything with them
that's a real problem putting these
things in the hands of a computer
algorithm was a really stupid decision
that computer algorithm had better be
dead on all the time or you just lost a
whole bunch of interactions that were
possibly very productive very creative
you're going against what Google is
supposed to be about so that's a big
problem I like to think of what's going
on is sort of like the metaphor of plate
tectonics we're only seeing a bit of the
problem right now there could be even
deeper problems that this is this is
heralding or signifying that's something
worth thinking about think about how
dependent we are on Google doing their
job effectively on YouTube doing their
job effectively on facebook on Twitter
and LinkedIn you know just all across
the the web these major platforms or you
know Apple Microsoft you know if itunes
fails think about how
get screwed up in the process these are
real issues there's something seriously
worth thinking about here that's bigger
than just comment sections and maybe
i'll talk about that in some later
videos but i want to get back to this
problem of comment sections so here's
the the fifth thing what is what is
going on Google's idea and I don't want
to just bash google you know because I
think what they're doing in some
respects is a great idea they want to
make interactions more social so they
want to create the possibility of having
chains of conversation that can can go
on longer that can involve more people
that can be a little bit more focused
and I think that's a great idea I'm not
going to knock that I think that that's
a positive I think it's also very
positive that now we can go longer than
500 characters because you know frankly
when I'm writing responses to people
about philosophy videos sometimes I need
more than 500 characters you know
especially if they're asking me some
complicated questions or making some
interesting points where the the problem
is coming in is that they have cut off a
lot of the very people who they are
trying to help I'll come back to that in
a moment I want to talk about another
feature that I think is is a good
intention they by adding this this spam
filter and you know the capacity to to
approve or disapprove of certain common
terms they're trying to they're trying
to take a stand on something that's a
fundamental problem in the net and has
been really from from the start of
public involvement in it and that's
trolling and flaming they are trying in
effect by some of the changes that they
they are rolling out to make the the
internet and to maybe YouTube a more
civil platform
there's a lot of implications involved
there that that really need to be
explored and so in I'll do some of that
in some future videos but I think that
on the whole I can get behind that
getting back to the fundamental problem
it's that they rolled out these changes
in such a way that they did two things
one is they cut off all the previous
conversations so you know what is all
that stuff that people have invested a
lot of time a lot of energy a lot of
thought in including myself but I'm
thinking about my viewers I mean I have
seven thousand subscribers and not
everybody who comments on my videos is
actually a subscriber so that means for
every you know our i put in creating
video and in responding to comments
there's tons of people out there putting
in hundreds of hours maybe thousands of
hours watching this stuff thinking about
it writing something responding to other
people engaging in a conversation so who
you just sort of pushed them all aside
and said everything you've done up to
this point doesn't matter that's a big
problem because people don't like to
hear that what they've done doesn't
matter that it's not real and now notice
what this this technology google could
just snap its fingers and all everything
that anybody has written up until that
point could just vanish that's a big
that's a big issue I certainly wouldn't
want that to happen to me it shows us
the vulnerability that we have to these
Giants making making decisions they're
doing another thing too so there were
two things that they were doing that's
that's that's wrong they are alienating
the very public that they most want to
incorporate it's as if they think that
viewers who just sign on
are more important than viewers who've
been with them for a long time that's
always a mistake for a company to make
it's it's a tempting one and you know a
lot of people do this in personal life
too or they do this in their
professional life they they lose their
old contacts because the new ones are
more interesting they forget their old
friends because the the new ones are
more interesting and have more to offer
to them Google's effectively doing that
with how they're rolling out these
changes that's that's a real problem
that shows a lack of prudence that's
quite alarming I skipped over something
and I want to come back to it actually
this is a good segue into it that one of
the things that I wanted to talk about
was we've got these gigantic platforms
out there that have a lot of control
over things that are now very important
to those of us that are tapped into the
net who have invested a good portion of
our lives and efforts and content and
livelihood even for some of us into
theirs cut there's this constant
jockeying for position between the the
big top tier ones like Google Apple
Microsoft who else would fit in their
facebook they're always trying to bring
out new products to integrate more
things there they're competing with each
other very much like great power
dynamics and then there's you know the
second tier of things where it quite
often they do well if they just stick to
what they're good at like LinkedIn
Twitter you know all those sorts of
sorts of things and there's this concept
that I call platform plurality all of
the great ones are always competing with
each other by trying to absorb a greater
share of the market by doing what the
other one
so Facebook for a while trying to get
into doing email and it was just
complete complete flop you know there
was no point to it image-sharing you
know are they going to do that aren't
they going to do that are they going to
offer the capacity to do editing in that
you know where are things going to be
downloaded how much of an experience of
the idea should Google bring out google
glass you know would Facebook ever
consider doing something like that would
Apple ever consider doing something like
that they're always trying to expand and
introduce more and more things and
integrate them within their system and
they always have their way of looking at
things this is a problem for google this
is a huge problem these days for Apple
who is declining equality it's a big
problem for facebook it's a big problem
for Microsoft and I am a proponent of
what I call platform plurality I don't
want to see any of these these big
behemoths ever win I want their always
to be a number of different platforms
that are that that can communicate with
each other so for example in Pinterest
you can share to twitter you can share
to facebook but I don't want pinterest
just sucked up and turned into one
little tool of this gigantic
conglomerate any more than I want
learnist or any of these I don't want
facebook to ever absorb Google I don't
want Google to ever absorb facebook I
want them to be distinctively different
and to be able to do different things
and not to be able to dominate the the
market completely I like the fact that
YouTube can share to twitter can share
to LinkedIn can share to these these
other platforms I don't want to see you
to become an exclusively google product
because that's actually bad for
everybody else and it's bad for me so
I'm always suspicious every time that I
see some new roll out like this where
there's greater integration it needs to
be done well YouTube is a community and
the mere fact that Google happens to own
that that company happens to have that
as a product
that doesn't mean that Google actually
owns the hearts and minds and
allegiances of the YouTube community
google has a responsibility to do do
right by them to observe sort of the the
norms of that community not just to
shape it however it likes well you know
i'd say that's actually a moral
responsibility when you get that large
that you actually control a significant
part of our our Technosphere you might
say but even if we just put in business
terms if you mess with that sort of
stuff you're stupid I mean Google you
know have this this great thing that I
always made fun of in class they're
their ethics was don't be evil how about
change it to don't be stupid now let me
go since education is young stupidity
and talk about the last thing I want to
talk about how are these changes to
comments affecting the use of YouTube as
an educational tool because that's why
I'm on YouTube it's not to make a ton of
money because i'm not actually I'm
barely making anything off of AD revenue
and it's not to become a superstar
because that's not happening either
although it is interesting that when I
go to conference there's always somebody
says yeah I know you from somewhere why
am I doing this I get tons of comments
from people who are saying what I'm
doing is helpful for them that and a lot
of the comments that I get are people
saying I can't afford to go to
university right now I couldn't ever go
to university I'm glad that you you're
providing this this content because I'm
able to use it to you know further my
own education as a lifelong learner and
I have students who are happy because
what I'm giving them helps them out in
their classes YouTube is this
extraordinary culture of opportunity for
disseminating education in a way that
transcends all these sorts of barriers
that have stood in the way for a long
time
particularly class and nationality and
you know access to things so there i'm
not saying that it you know it's
something utopian or anything like that
there's a lot that would need to be done
to expand it further but youtube is this
amazing platform for education and
they've even created youtube edu to try
to support that and i think that's a
great thing not being able to do
comments the way that it's traditionally
been done even if you add in the new
features is a bad thing not being able
to incorporate or respond to past
comments on the videos that are
currently already out there some of
which have been out there for a long
time and have had extensive
conversations taking place which are
participatory and our educational this
is doing harm to the ability of these
videos to be elements of people's
education google really did not think
the this stuff through now you know
again it seems like what they want to do
i'm not going to say this is all just a
business decision and trying to get on
capture market for g+ or anything i'm
not going to take the cynical route i'm
going to say yeah i understand that they
actually have a vision of community that
they want to try to further by this new
comment stuff and they want to do it
through google plus infusing itself into
to youtube all of that is good but
you've already built a community youtube
built communities and you need to
respect those communities before you
start building new ones again is the
problem of do you dismiss all your old
friends when they're the one
who are supporting you in your very
quest to have new friends it's a you
know that's a moral problem ansys you
know it's a Prudential even business
problem you don't screw all your own
clients and just move on to new clients
when your old clients are the ones
paying your bills do providing you with
your capital whether it's it's you know
monetary or social or market share I
guess where I'm going to close is I
think what Google ought to think about
and of course you know I'm pretty small
potato so I don't think Google is going
to respond to me or you're going to
google spokesperson is correspond to me
but this is worth having a conversation
about so actually i'll say two things
one is you have to ask the question why
should we youtube content producers
continue putting in all this time effort
work thought and development to
developing high quality educational
resources for a platform that might
screw us over and that's really what
they did here screw us over it showed us
our vulnerability to google executives
and you know who knows what other you
know some teams making decisions that
affect all of us can affect the way in
which we can communicate you my viewers
and myself why should we contribute to
the value of youtube i mean here's the
thing to remember take away all the
lolcat videos and animal stuff and and
you know beauty tips and and you know
record reviews and all these other
things what is YouTube is it just about
entertainment is it just about lifestyle
or is it about education if the great
value of YouTube is that it's the best
value of YouTube is actually as
something that's going to provide an
education or at least the elements of
Education for this generation and for a
few
generations and create communities of
learners and of thought why the hell
should we keep on investing all of our
time and labor into a platform that
doesn't know what it wants to be that's
a big question to think about so the
last thing I'm going to say is again
there we go all the way back to full
circle those of you are watching this
and commenting on it it's going to be an
experiment to see whether we're able to
actually interact the way Google seems
to intend for us to on this new video
because this is post Google takeover of
YouTube at least as far as comments goes
so if you want comment on this I may not
be able to respond to your comments as
of the time that I'm shooting this video
I was not able to actually respond to
people's comments even though they were
being done through the proper channels
in Google+ hopefully Google will
straighten all this stuff out if they do
then I will respond to all the comments
that people put on this video if not if
you don't see any comments from me
you'll know exactly why and who's to
blame